welcome back ladies and gents to another
video today we're talking about seven
seeds imagine this you're living a
normal day in your life maybe you're out
with friends spending time with your
girlfriend or just walking alone in the
street then you suddenly wake up in a
strange new world surrounded by five
strangers on a rapidly sinking boat in
the middle of a storm for natsu this is
her new reality when suddenly some lady
opens up the door and asks her to follow
and hurry up as they're about to sink
and there's no time the girl realizes
she's on a ship it's raining and the
storm's building up she's supposed to
jump onto the rescue boat that's already
located with a bunch of characters whom
we've yet to be introduced to so far
they're just four survivors on the boat
a painfully shiaty natsu a braided woman
who seems to be leading the group named
botan a long-haired boy semi-maru and
arashi the nice guy nobody can recall
what happened the last night and how
they ended up being on the ship the
group reaches a cliff comes across an
island and splits up in search for food
then we're taken to a scene where a girl
named hannah is fleeing from a swarm of
skittering beetles she outruns them
takes water from a waterfall and then is
attacked by a swarm of stark white
red-eyed praying mantises two guys rush
to rescue her but one of them the team
leader is stabbed in the back with a
stinger the size of a bayonet he makes
it out alive but the sting appears to
intensify his already aggressiveness
they're part of a group of individuals
who are camping on a large wooden raft
tied to three inflatable rafts the group
leader leads an attempt to flee the
island but their raft is destroyed by a
storm and they're washed back later
while having a quarrel with his team
members he falls into a pit full of huge
manta sees but soon returns to the group
seemingly unharmed but displeased
somewhere else on the island six people
awaken from cryogenic cells in an
unidentified metal room when their
leader enters the room the others draw
their weapons and fire at him they fire
before he can say what the hell's going
on he curses them as he falls to the
ground arashi becomes unwell after
eating mushrooms collected by natsu but
he quickly heals after he decides to run
off with natsu as the other two members
seem suspicious they're trapped by
carnivorous plants and attacked by giant
rats but are saved by mozu who's also a
survivor who got separated from his
group arashi asks if he knows why
they're on the island and mozu explains
that they're part of a governmental
survival experiment bolton outlines the
seven seeds project she explains that
the scientists predicted a meteorite
would hit the earth prompting the world
to launch a project called the seven
seeds they selected young and healthy
people and put them into cryo-sleep and
after it was determined that the world
was inhabitable they would be released
the japanese government divides the
people into five categories winter
spring summer a summer b and four each
group comprises of seven people who are
kept in the dark about what will happen
before being cryogenically preserved as
well as one adult guide who's been
educated in wilderness survival there
are also sealed shelters with seedlings
and instruction books near the seven
fuji these seven fuji are not related to
the famous mount fuji but are regional
landmarks also named fuji as a result of
the change climate homicidal enormous
insects have emerged and the groups must
adjust to their new surroundings while
trying to figure out what's happened to
the earth meanwhile hana's leader guides
his group back to the waterfall where
they encounter the giant insects he then
leads them into a tunnel which is
actually a trap because he's been
infected with insect larvae however in
the last moment in order to save the
others he burns himself on fire and
instructs them to look for the seven
fujis the crew returns to the shore to
construct a new raft and is ready to
sail to the closest fuji board's group
comes upon three individuals who are
being threatened by a crocodile in a
pond and she rushes in to save them
they're the remaining members of summer
team b according to bolton natsu learns
they're on an island in a lake so they
make a raft and set out to reach the
mainland they arrive and start looking
for food but they also discover the
nagasaki pea statue submerged botan
decides to travel to the nearest fuji
natsu comes upon the entrance to one of
the sealed shelters with the goods
needed for survival and self-sufficiency
later one of the members chooses to pay
a visit to his hometown natsu and arashi
join him only to discover that it's
submerged anashi resolves to return to
tokyo in the hope of finding his
girlfriend hana natsu follows him and
later semimaru eventually joins them
they come across several other humans
along the way the trio realized they've
stumbled onto the full team village the
team's been there for three years the
three travelers are tangled up when
semimaru tries to steal some food the
fourth team leader frees the three
prisoners but later decides to poison
them and everyone else in the group
because he believes the seven seeds
project has failed fortunately though
semiwaru suspects that the water's
poison and prevents the others from
drinking it right after the trio departs
as they're in trouble launching their
inflatable boat the fall team leader
comes and helps them so they can
continue their voyage to eastern japan
after reaching there they discover
another locked shelter but it's flooded
and useless they continue their voyage
and come across to another ruin arashi
jumps into the water and gets attacked
by a big fish he's saved by a bearded
man who introduces himself as takahiro
as it turns out he's the only survivor
from the winter team and it's almost 15
years that he's been surviving on his
own the trio flee throughout the night
fearful of takahiro he's alone with his
dogs once more meanwhile the spring
teams hana and haru paddle their boat
through the city's submerged ruins they
spend the night in an abandoned church
before returning to the squad the next
day they decide to make the place they
are as a base while exploring the area
hana is being pursued by a dinosaur-like
thing but takahiro and his dogs save her
despite considerable skepticism dakahiro
gets accepted into the spring team he
tells about three people he's met before
hannah thinks one of the three people is
her boyfriend arashi later hana comes
into contact with the plant that
takahiro claims is toxic and she begins
to show symptoms she decides to leave
the group and find anashi to avoid
infecting the others while sailing on
the boat she's thrown into the ocean by
a big fish she concludes that life isn't
worth living but dakahiro saves her and
transports her to the island where
summer team b first set foot her health
however continues to deteriorate and she
sets out on her own preparing to die she
regains her will to live when she finds
a message carved on the rock by arashi
takahiro thinks the salt can help hana
heal by neutralizing the poison so he
looks for a salty pond dakahiro haru and
hana return to the four teams base only
to find it deserted and blacketed in
volcanic ash meanwhile arashi and his
companions discover more treasure as
well as a sailboat they decide to return
on the sailing boat and rejoin their
squad now back to hana and the others
they discover a tunnel entrance beneath
as well as two members of the fall team
later at night someone of the full team
apprehends haru who claims to have heard
a sound of a motor when hana's group go
find him the four team takes by force
their inflatable raft and moves further
into the underground system which
appears to be an evacuation complex they
find that power is available and they
access the computer system meanwhile
hana's group also explore another part
of the complex where they find a dead
body and a diary the diary details that
hana's father engaged a ventriloquist
and other entertainers for a new
underground theme park soon the meteor
slammed into earth obliterating the
surface the facility wasn't able to cope
with the disaster and eventually the
food supplies ran out then a deadly
virus spread throughout the facility and
it was sealed off to prevent the disease
from spreading the final survivors were
frozen to death and the ventriloquist
was last to die ending his own life
as the seven seed survivors emerge from
the complex they're confronted by armed
personnel wearing protective equipment
who accuse them of spreading the x-virus
as they escape from the compound the
full team leader gets shot by the armed
personnel while saving his team member
the armed group decides that the virus
has most likely already been released
and abandons the teams as the team
leader is dying he tells hana that
arashi was the one who inspired him to
stay alive and support his team later
when the seven seeds return to team
springs camp they discover that it's
been demolished and that the members
have gone missing takahiro recommends
that they continue to his former camp in
the meantime arashi natsu and semimaru
learn to sail the boat and come across a
girl floating in the water who looks
like their team member hotaru after
rescuing her it turns out that she's not
hotaru but a member of the spring team
and she claims that hotaru is dying
elsewhere summer team a discovers a boy
from team spring they seem to want to
take care of him but actually they
experiment food and medical remedies on
him they then used him as bait to
attract predators that they may later
hunt down and kill for food summer team
a's well-designed camp is discovered by
hana and the others and they understand
they were the ones who shot the full
team leader dakahiro sets up a
distraction while hana tries to save the
boy but they're apprehended meanwhile
hana's team captures a girl from summer
a team who come across haru they offered
to exchange her for the kid sadly
takahiro and the camp are assaulted by a
colony of white carnivorous bats which
everyone works together to overcome
summer team a and the other groups
gradually learn to work together despite
some hostility between them together
they hatch a strategy to exterminate the
back colony using music composed by haru
summer teammate also assists with the
treatment of the other's sickness when
ango a member of summer a team learns
that hana is the daughter of a professor
who trained him he informs everyone
about the summer team a program after a
flashback he expresses hatred towards
hannah as a result of her affiliation
with her father and his crew hana wants
to leave the camp because ango tried to
rape her takahiro and haru offer to
accompany her meanwhile arashi and his
team arrive near the full team's
abandoned village natsu discovers a note
from hana addressed to anashi but she's
hesitant to give it to him natsu and
semimaru later come upon their team
member who informs them that bothan and
another member are in danger after
saving them natsu gives arashi hana's
note meanwhile hana is forced to
accompany the group in their quest for a
water source underground rio and hana go
further down into the cave in search of
water then suddenly rio cuts hannah's
rope and lets her fall to her death
because he worries she's making ango
psychologically ill the rest of the
group decides to look for hana meanwhile
hana has survived the fall and is
searching for water she meets ango while
they're arguing ango comes towards her
and she slips into the water when the
others arrive she exclaims that rio
can't be trusted as they prepare to
rescue hana the water carries her away
did hana really die by the end of season
one this was a major cliffhanger and
we're not going to spoil anything for
you to find out what happens next you've
got to watch 7 seed season 2. we hope to
see you in the next video until then
stay safe and happy bye